okay good morning everyone and apologies
for the delay we had a slight technical
issue this end which we've resolved and
can i welcome everyone to this meeting
of development control committee a at
mid-south district council i can just
first of all run some of the through
some of the domestic arrangements
can i ask that your microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt interrupt other speakers or
hold separate conversations while others
are speaking and if you are attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
can i just ask you to double check your
mobile phones are on silent and can i
also ask that your laptop so also the
volume is turned down so that when
messages come in they don't ping away
um we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting
on the modern.gov app so please good
members make sure they are logged in and
ready to use the app
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewings the whole of the meeting will
be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if you do hear the fire alarm sound
today please leave the building
immediately via the fire exit to make
your way to the assembly point at
ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exited each end of the floor please
do not enter the atrium if you're in the
atrium the timely alarm follow the signs
to the nearest fire exit please do not
use the stairs or the lifts
and do not re-enter the building to it
is safe to do so
okay good so we'll just do some
introductions
so uh this meeting due to um members not
some sorry some officers not being able
to come into the chamber today
we have some people who are online
which we're going to trial
we have ian de prez our legal officer
who is online but in the room we have
philip isabel the chief planning officer
we have bradley heffer and elizabeth
thomas who are the case officers who
present
sasha tiller who's the housing enabling
officer will be virtual
and we have uh all the support team
around us that keeps everything ticking
over
so um i'll move just for the benefit of
members that may not have been to a
planning meeting before
myself as one of the district
councillors matthew and my colleagues
here on my left
will decide the applications before us
today we may
in mid suffolk not vote on an
application in our own ward
so moving straight on
to the agenda uh apologies for absence
do we have any pleas
okay thank you do we need to receive any
declarations of disclosable pecuniary
interests and other registrable or
non-registerable interests by members
casa humphreys
and non-binary i'm a member of stone
market town council thank you
okay
any decorations of lobbying
i'm guessing
well for me it's been on the newton road
yes i don't think you need to because
you're not on the committee
um
sorry declarations of interest we'd all
had emails on newton road yep
and
so that's registered thank you
um
any decorations of personal site visits
by members
none received thank you
okay so confirmation the minutes of the
meeting held on the 22nd of june are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the minutes
nope so could i ask to have a proposer
and a seconder for those council
e-burning councillor passmore thank you
the government's office will now conduct
an electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
okay
thank you chair that's five votes four
and three abstentions that's carried
thank you
thank you
okay so we'll move on uh do we need to
receive any notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
okay so we'll move straight on to the
first application we have two before us
today the first one is dc20
01036 ash's farm newton road stone
market and i'll now invite the case
officer bradley heffer to introduce the
application to the committee
if those are following online wish to
speak if you just raise your hands in
the normal way we will be monitoring the
hands up function here on our laptops to
bring you in at the appropriate time
bradley over to you
thank you
well good morning members um
this first item you're being asked to
consider an outline application for the
erection of up to 300 dwellings
on land ash's farm newton road stone
market
although the application is submitted in
outline
and all details are reserved the
proposal does seek full planning
permission
for the means of vehicle access to the
site which is being taken or proposed to
be taken
off newton road
this slide shows the application site in
the context of the wider area
you will note the site's position in
relation to
stone market itself
abutting the
the edge of stone market
um you also note the line
of the a14
trunk road
um
which goes to the north of the the
identified site
and start upland
to the north east
this is a larger scale aerial view of
the site and and it's worth noting on
this plan the site is
bisected
by
newton road which runs from north to
south
on that plan
other things to point out are the um
obviously you can see that the trunk
road again
larger scale and stow upland road which
leads up to star upland
the other thing to point out on this
slide is that
this site
directly abuts a site
known as diapers farm
and we have a current full planning
application
on diapers farm
so the land
to the i think that is listed
on page 22 in the agenda so there is a
full application on the land adjacent
which is under consideration
um at the present time
so
just so you're aware of that and
this site we're talking about today
immediately
above that side
this is the red line application site
it's worth noting on this particular
plan that the land that is currently
occupied by
the allotments
newton road allotments
is shown
as being edged blue but the allotment
land is not
part of the planning application site
as part of the development you're being
asked to consider
the access road adjacent to
the
allotment site which comes out onto
newton road
is part of the application site but the
um
the allotment site itself
edge blue but it's not part of this one
this is the constraints map um
it looks a bit confusing at first glance
but in effect
um
you'll note that the two areas of land
to the west of newton road are covered
by flood zones
the area to the east of newton road
which is the area that is proposed to
locate the residential development on
is within flood zone one
you also note the brown line which is
the edge of the built-up boundary
uh of stone market
and it's also
sailing to point out that you have a
proud public right of way which crosses
the site
across the top
at this point here
and continues through the adjacent site
diapers farm
and out onto
stone upland road
the other thing i'd point out and
it's noted in the report of course is
that ash's farm itself is a grade two
listed building
as part of the consideration of
development on this site over a lengthy
period of time
um starting with a stone market area
action plan
and subsequent development uh sorry
subsequent production development brief
um the site we're considering today is
look uh is is identified as zone one
within that brief
the other piece of land
which we're also considering as part
today for for open space purposes is not
within the brief itself
but the remainder of the site
is in zone one
of the um the council's
brief
for the site
um leading on from that the
development brief does include a concept
plan
which includes um
some high level suggestions or
recommendations on how that site could
be developed
you'll note from that drawing
the point of access of newton road
and
a fairly um
indicative line here
or illustrative line there of
where the um
access through from newton road
all the way through the site and now out
onto stow upland road
this will be a rough line of where that
would be
there's also indications on here or
where density of development may be
appropriate higher density shown in the
the flesh tone you've got there lower
density
in the lighter tone
and also arrangement of open space
and this also picks up the use of the
site on the west of newton road
um for open space um as is proposed on
the piece of land to the south which
also forms part of the application site
the application you're being asked to
consider today is obviously had to be
cognizant of the
details in the master plan sorry in the
in the council's development brief
and this plan the illustrative master
plan the companies are planning
application
as members are aware the illustr
illustrative status of this
means it's an indicate what's not an
indication it's an illustration of how
the site could be
um
arranged
but i think that in terms of the
arrangement of of development on the
previous slide which you saw which i'll
quickly flick back to
just to remind you
and the details shown on this
uh slide which does accompany the plan
application
officers considered that there's a
a synergy between the two in terms of
the way the site would be used
um i think it's worth saying at this
stage although that the point of access
again of newton mode is something that
fall planning pollution being sought for
what you see in terms of a a road layout
there is illustrative um and it's not
something that you should necessarily
set too much store in terms of detail
because that would fire in the reserve
matters
application
um the other thing to point out of
course which is one of the key
considerations here is
that there has to be a link through from
this site to the diapers farm site
that's indicated in the
the red line sorry the
the arrow you can see
that point there
but the intention the clear intention
the development of all of this site is
having a link through from luton road to
stone upland road
um as part of the planning application
there are various improvements proposed
to the wider
newton road area
this is a large scale plan but the
following drawings
hope we can drill down to
more detail on those particular elements
this is the site access that's
planning permission is being sought for
for planning commission
this meets with the requirements of the
highway authority in terms of gaining an
access to serve that number of units on
that land
um
it's point point out on this particular
drawing that
there would be a footpath provided as
part of the bell mouth access
coming into the site
and then there would be an informal
crossing point
pedestrian crossing at this point and
the provision of a new footpath down
towards the junction of newton road with
spring row
because that's not there at the moment
and then that will lead through this is
the footpath i was just talking about
here
that will lead through
to spring row and there will be another
crossing point at this point pedestrian
crossing point
and there is an existing footpath from
that point
but the proposal was to widen because at
the moment it's quite narrow
so it's proposed to widen down
to this point here
and
then the other elements that um are
proposed are
almost a formalization and organization
of the parking spaces to the front this
is the um
the um allotment land is a formalization
of the parking spaces in in the highway
to the front of that
and this is the access
which is shown under the ownership of
the applicant which is adjacent to
the um
to the
allotments
um the other one element i've
pick up on this drawing is on the on the
far right you'll see a footpath there
it's proposed to introduce a pedestrian
crossing at that point um but widen the
footpath
um because at the moment again it is
quite narrow
various views this is leading into the
site
heading southwards along newton mode you
clearly see the
the bridge the a14 trunk road which
crosses newton road
something i admitted to say in the early
drawings is that
one of the elements that would also be
required as part of the highway works
would be the relocation of the 30 mile
an hour speed limit along that road
and it would actually
be somewhere to the front of the
the bridge
as you look at the photograph from its
current position so it would be
the 30 mile an hour limit would be
extended northwards
and there would also be some
localized carriageway narrowing just to
reduce down the speed
further for cars
in that area
this is generally where the um
the main access would come just past the
town sign
this is the proposed location of the new
access onto newton road
the application plans identify that
there is sufficient room within the land
and the highway to provide the vision
splays that required
this is um various views of the land to
the west of newton road which is
being
proposed for
informal recreational purposes um as
part of the
overall scheme
this is the land as i said previously
recall is is within the flood plain it's
got clear ecological value potential
but there's no proposals to actually
develop this land for residential
purposes
um it be left
very much as it is as an amenity
resource
and that is a requirement of the
development plan or the development
brief
that
the council
created
that's a smaller area of open space that
would also be
um
part of that that overall open space
offer
that's where the 30 mile an hour speed
limit ends currently which i was talking
about that will go to the other side of
the bridge
which you can see in the distance
and that is ashley's farm itself
um grade two listed building you can see
on the right um set in a fairly large
cartilage and there are associated farm
buildings that are just out of shot to
the left as you look at that that
photograph which are accessed as is the
house now
via
a different access coming off of newton
remote
that's a view down newton road as
looking south we've you see the flint
wall um
of the curtains of the listed building
and the verge you can see on the right
behind there you can't actually see in
the photograph unfortunately is the
footpath i was referring to which is
there but would be widened as part of
the works
this is an interface between the site
the southern end of the site and
existing development in
newton road just to give you an idea of
how the site would look it's not
proposed to remove any of the hedging
as part of the development because it's
clearly an asset so
that boundary it's intended
would look very much as is
but again you will note there's a
footpath
on the um the right hand side in front
of the dwellings
this is a shot sewing showing the access
onto
newton road from the
service road that basically provides
access to the rear of properties in
stowe upland road at the moment and
you'll also note the um the parking
spaces at the front of the allotments
as part of the scheme it's proposed to
have a pedestrian crossing installed in
that location there
so that
there is a crossing point available
these are various views of the land
looking from the south having walked up
that access view
you can see it sorry access road you can
see the views it's it's former
agricultural land there is um
a fall from
from the a14 north end
down to the um
newton road stone upland end if it's the
best way to describe it so there is a
fall on the land which is obviously
something that any new development would
have to take into account
so there's some more views of that
that's the junction of newton road and
stow upland road and you'll see on the
left there the footpath i was referring
to
which will be widened as part of the
works
the other thing i hadn't mentioned but
you have hopefully picked up from the
report is that as part of the traffic
impacts associated with this development
um
improvements will be required to the
a1120
b treble 1 5 junction at stow upland
we've had
various discussions with the developer
of this site
the developer of the adjacent diapers
farm site and also the potential
developer of land that's not even
allocated development for development in
stowe upland
it's a jlp allocation but
as we all know at this stage that
doesn't really mean anything in terms of
an allocation but we have to be mindful
of that
the memorandum of understanding is that
clear trigger points would be
in place
um whereby improvements this junction
would be secured
it's likely to take the form
of a roundabout junction rather than the
priority junction you can see at the
moment
those works would be carried out under
section 278 the highways act to the
requirements of the highway authority
and would be funded by the developers as
part of their agreement
um so there would be that memorandum of
understanding well that's already been
signed
between the parties
um and reference to it would be made
within the section 106 agreement
that would be secured with us and the
county council so be absolutely clear
what the requirements are and when the
trigger points for the provision of
those works are
again it's worth saying that
the trigger point would be across
all three sites so regardless of which
site managed to start first
build rates or anything like that there
will be a clear indication that when the
trigger is reached
across all three sites um the works have
to
have to be commenced and completed again
within another trigger period which
again is described in mine
in my report
i think that's all i need to say at this
stage the one thing i would
refer
members to in closing is
the
table papers
um
the recommendation to members has been
amended slightly because
um in summary we are still
looking at
the amount of affordable housing
provision in terms of the mix that's
preferred by
our strategic housing team
when this first came in
the application came in
no affordable housing was being offered
and
that's been one of the reasons that it's
taken quite some time to get to
committee because we've we've been
through a viability assessment
um and we've established that
affordable housing is achievable on site
notwithstanding the
the extensive mitigation package which
is listed in my report which would be
part of the section 106.
um
so
but the actual details of the mix of the
development
to be secured well there's more there's
some explanatory comments underneath but
generally we still need to
finally establish that mix so
if members are happy with that variation
to recommendation that would enable us
to carry on those discussions
the other thing i have to point out that
we did originally seek a travel plan
contribution but the travel plan
officers since advised that that can be
dealt with by planning condition albeit
there'd still be a requirement for a
monitoring monitoring fee
so
again that's been factored in
that change has been factored into the
viability in relation to
affordable housing
and the last thing
to avoid any confusion whatsoever there
is a
comment in paragraph eight of my report
which refers to
a junction alteration
um having checked again
uh this this is basically within stone
market um
and it's not something that's supported
by the highway authority so they're not
actually asking for that to take place
because they think that the issues that
could be
raised with regard to that junction can
be tackled by changing the timing of the
lights
so they wouldn't need to do what they're
proposing to do
and the highway authority have said that
they don't support that so just to make
that absolutely clear but i think um
that's all i need to
say at the moment
can i just ask the first question can we
just go back to affordable housing so i
i see in the late recommendation you're
talking about a split 75 20 percent
sorry 75 25 and the amount could be
achieved on the site could be 18
uh why only 18
i mean the site and what is the site
down the road achieved because you would
think the viability would be the same i
mean there's there's nothing
particularly complex about this site
compared to the other site down in stone
the 18
figure
is based on the 75 25 split which is the
preferred figure
of the housing team in relation to this
particular site
up until
fairly recently the mix
was different um there was i can't
remember at the top of my head
unfortunately but there was um a
different mix so i'm sure about the 18
yeah why is it 18 and not 30.
i think this it's been tested through
viability chair and um that's what we're
advised by available viability advisors
achievable on this site while still so
we're saying that but the developers
saying zero
no no they've agreed they've agreed
okay fine i misunderstood that thank you
okay yeah councilor madison
thank you yeah the the um perhaps the
sticky question probably for mr isabel
first
um
why why
is it bearing in mind that the the um
the policy saap the allocation and so on
is of these the two sites of ash's farm
and diaper
why did we need to bring this one
forward in a now
in advance of the diaper one being ready
to come to committee
um
and would it therefore not have been
better to
look at the two at the same time so that
we know we're getting what we're looking
for in the policies
push the right button
thank you chairman
so you've obviously got a development
brief on this which was prepared a few
years ago um and that identifies uh the
three zones that i think bradley talked
about
uh from our point of view that gives us
enough guidance to consider and report
to you on the application
um and they they are the development
brief the policies are intended to guide
how this comes forward
uh and from our perspective we've done
the viability work to get to the bottom
of uh the question of what can be
achieved in terms of affordable housing
there's no reason why we would
not take this to a conclusion at this
point because we have the information
that we believe gets us to where we need
to
the
treatment of the
the total allocation in three steps as
it were
is anticipated in the development brief
and this is one way of achieving that
thank you counselor
thank you chair um i've got five
questions so do you want me to just do
three and come back or i could give two
at a time but you might as well get
through them all
because you may find other people gonna
ask the same questions so um
okay thank you um the um
i don't know what the name of the track
is that goes behind the steps and road
houses but that's
can i just confirm that that's not being
used for access but only for walking and
cycling
um
the has there been a discussion about um
having any more allotments i don't know
what the need is and and whether it's
oversubscribed take those two then come
back another two do two at a time
bradley
sorry um the track to the side of the
allotments um is shown as being under
the ownership of control of the
applicant but it's not being proposed
for any access
in terms of
cycling and pedestrian
not there is no
nothing in front of us to suggest that
there is a proposal to do that the link
that is being uh proposed is from
the corner of the site where it meets
the existing public right-of-way which
comes out further along stone upland
road
so there there is a link there but it's
not coming out at that point
the second part the allotments um
that they haven't formed part of any
discussions is not proposed to do
anything to the allotments at all
because the land is not part of
the planning application
sorry
not any new ones on the site no no okay
thanks
thank you chair um
thank you for that
brad um with regards to open space um
it's a kind of departure from the
stonework area action plan because it
said that there should be a um retainer
separation between stone market and
stuff and along the north side and
there's just one patch
of
um land there um
is there being any was there any
consideration to make to increase that
area
and then a second
question the
memorandum of understanding for the
roundabout junction
on the b1115
a double one two o
if
if only one of the three developments
goes ahead
will that junction still happen when the
75th house is met thank you
yes thank you councillor the the open
space um
the indication um of arrangement of open
space is
sorry
the illustration of the arrangement of
open space is is just that at the moment
in terms of
getting principles established on the
site where development come would go i
think it's it's looking to
establish that
the advice in the spd has been followed
with regard to how the overall site
works i think that what i haven't
discussed in my report sorry in my
presentation but is in the report
is that from the saps inception
and then post
spd
there's been an uplift in the number of
units that's deemed appropriate for the
site so therefore that's in it that will
have an impact on the amount of open
space that's achievable on the site but
obviously
as part of a reserve matters application
we would look to
secure
as much open spaces in accordance with
the arrangement
within the spd
the other thing is with regards to the
memorandum of
understanding um
it doesn't really matter who
um
you know if if the discus sorry if the
agreement is there that the works will
take place
um whoever starts building
is liable to them
and that's across the three sites so if
two of the sites didn't happen then the
third site of that started that that
would still
create the requirement
um thank you very much
and the fifth one sorry on the um
the the total housing across the two
sides um
of
ash's pharma diapers farm supposed is
now
would be five five eight and that's 40
up
on what the stonework air reaction plan
had now i understand that's in the
development brief
and that um
but a lot has changed since the
development brief you know we've seen
that with a joint local plan so
can you just confirm why we need to
you know there's such a
massive increase mr israel wants to come
in on that point
well actually depends i mean i just
didn't want to point out the development
brief guides us the the joint local plan
is not part of the development plan the
uh
allocation and then the development
brief the allocation is a
part of the development plan the
development brief is a material
consideration having been consulted upon
and adopted
and that guides the delivery of all of
these phases it looks at the detail of
how you bring this allocation out of out
of the ground and that's where that's
where the numbers are specified and
they're specified relative to degrees of
sensitivity in landscape terms in parts
so
that's driven out of it i'm not sure if
that's an answer to your question in
relation to time and these policy
documents they're still perfectly
relevant they are still relevant to
guide
what we see before us this morning
because they're not been superseded by
any other policy document
um thank you very much for that yeah
it's just the fact that if the overall
allocation for the two sizes 400 and the
development brief is a guide that's just
what i wanted a you know
confirmation on as it were thanks uh
council password you're an accident um
thanks matthew um rachel's asked some of
the questions i was gonna ask i won't
repeat those um not in any particular
order but there's um regarding this
junction improvement
um
i suppose the answer here is and this
also applies to things like nhs
contributions
we don't know exactly when this would
all start and so on is it up to the uh
how do we deal with the inflationary
effects of what might be required if you
look for example the nhs contribution i
was surprised it was as low as it is
um
and this may not be a planning matter
but
if this didn't start for two or three
years for example then by the time they
want to put extra facilities in you've
got up to i don't know 700 people is it
up to the nhs or highways to decide how
much they want or is there i see mr
isbell comment can comment on that
perfect you know thanks that's the first
one
um yes the the potential for uh prices
and uh inflation to have an effect on
values is something that would usually
be set out within one of the standard
clauses in the section 106 so that all
the figures can be indexed accordingly
so that you have a benchmark and you
know you then adjust them according to
the point in time where actually the
liability occurs
um and and that's pretty standard
practice in most section 106s
thank you thanks
just a couple of other things um
obviously i was pleased um with another
hat on here about um
design outcry more secured by design is
it possible to that's on page 105
is this may not be the right stage but
is it possible to condition that would
that come under reserve matters or not i
mean common sense should prevail but
that doesn't always happen of course
in other words there's a recommendation
is that now or is that something under
reserve matters we would deal with
um i'll i'll take that one cancer i mean
the you would have seen the comment
we've received from the
suffolk constabulary
i think
um and perhaps i didn't make it clear
enough in the report um
that sort of comment can inform
discussions in relation to creation of
the reserve matters
so i think that
whilst we can't
deal with that level of detail now
but the requirements i think that where
they're you know we were able to
accommodate those as part of a preserved
matter scheme then we can feed those in
as part of that overall process
if if i can add to that if it's a matter
of great import to the committee the
kind of way i deal with that is to add
an informative to
set that out on the decision notice that
the committee will expect that to be
followed if that's committee's wish
um
we're looking at the biodiversity i
think that comes under reserve matters
later on
and we've mentioned before things like
um different um bird boxes etc there's a
whole load of things there we deal with
that at the next stage
for reserve matters or do we need to
sell any now i think that the detail
would enable us to to consider that
properly and we've got
recommended ecological yeah you can see
that so um i think that the detail again
will allow us to deal with we do need to
discuss that today my last one about
matthew knows what i'm going to say with
extreme heat and water shortages and so
on about the layout and permeability of
driveways and the site and so on again
would that be done it's not a drainage
issue it's more about um
underground aquifers and not having
permeable surfaces so everything drains
straight into a ditch or flows away as
opposed to getting it to percolate into
the
into the ground is that something to
deal with now or later
again in terms of
the functionality of the roads
that's adopted roads would have to
achieve a certain standard
where they're not being offered for
adoption
i would imagine that alternative
material could be used which is
more permeable in all cases we'd look to
secure as much permeability as
as we can of course but i think you're
only being asked to consider the full
planning permission for the access at
the moment
sorry you can consider that at a later
stage okay thank you thank you matthew
that's all thank you carson
uh thank you chair i've got a few
questions related to highways and one on
a completely different matter so
i'll start with the highways um things
and i'll start with the one that hasn't
been mentioned before uh has there been
any discussion
about the new path uh on the northern
bit of newton road from spring road to
the
site entrance or wherever that bit of
path is going
has there been any discussion about
making that wide enough to be a cycle
way
and i also want to just make sure that
there is a guarantee that when the
diaper
site comes forward
there is going to be pedestrian and
cycle access
to stockland road is that sort of is
that guaranteed or is that just
what you've got on a plan
that's my first pair
um
the answers the first question is no
um
the width of the
footweight has been
accepted at two meters we haven't had
any discussions about making that wider
on the second point um
the full application for diapers will
enable us or does enable us to consider
the
issues of access
and also how it links into this site as
well because it's they are seeking a
full application
sorry for planning permission so we're
able to consider those elements um and
that's
something that
will be brought to planning committee so
you can see exactly how that would work
but we're very mindful of that
to try and improve the
links because that's one of the clear
requirements of the sap and also the um
the spd
there's no guarantee that it'll ever
happen
we can't condition it to make sure that
it happens
um i wouldn't think you could put a
condition on it but
um as usual with a section 106 you've
got a long list of things that are
under a section 106
and what you're talking about i guess
you can tell me if i'm wrong is about
avoiding a ransom strip situation where
you have a highway stop short of the
boundary so what you want is basically
public access
all the way through which is what the
allocation looks to do
i think that's something you put within
a section 106 and you wouldn't
necessarily write the detail of it but
what you want is the confidence that
that is managed
so whilst debate continues perhaps
if we give that some thought as officers
just so i understand you're talking
about making sure that there is
the opportunity for public access
between
this zone of the allocation and the
other zones
at so so that that is not interrupted
regardless of ownership this is about
usage
and it may well be that access is
available ahead of dedication but the
point is about
making sure this is
available when people are living there
is that
i'm am i taking that correctly it's just
that we often we often hear about things
and saying yes there's going to be uh
you know
that's in the in the master plan but
there's no i just want to make sure it
is actually going to happen where
because i've just looked for the diaper
site
planning application and i can't find it
so i was going to see what the what the
sort of plan looked like um because
clearly we're not looking at the two
things together and i just want to make
sure that that's yeah so let's if you
could just give that some thought for
them
my other questions uh one is to do with
the
um
junction improvement in stow upland
um which i vaguely remember some time
ago there was some discussion of putting
a pedestrian crossing to get to the
co-op
um and i don't know if that's happened
and it's whatever's planned there now i
i'm very skeptical
of uh
hypothetical highway improvements
because i presume that we don't have a
drawing or anything of what's going to
happen and whether it's going to be
safer better whatever however
superlative you want to use for it
because it's all
someone said says yes we'll do it are
you just referring to the crossing well
i'm worried that whatever whatever
happens there they're uh can you just
expect sorry can you just explain are
you talking about the crossing to the
co-op
yeah in stockland yeah yes that's
already there it's already there so but
it's not on the diagram we didn't see it
i don't know how far away it's going to
be from this roundabout is it going to
affect it it's already there is is the
roundabout that's going to be put there
and you'll affect it
there's some talk about putting a
roundabout on that junction is it going
to muck up the pedestrian crossing
well
bradley you come in but um
in terms of the final details of the
junction itself that is a condition of
the planning permission that we would
need to see those
um i can't show you a plan that
indicates or shows how that that that
junction will work at the moment and if
i could it would it would not be the
detail you're looking for because it's
got to obviously go through safety audit
and things like that but the actual
element is one of the um the bullet
points and the report
in the suggested conditions that we the
highway authority want to see that
detail as well as um the memorandum of
memorandum of understanding being in
place
so the issues around pedestrian
crossings and things like that
that can be
again looked at as part of that detail
when we're actually considering that
element as a condition of the permission
that that helps thank you well
my final question is is to do with the
market housing mix
we've mentioned you've mentioned
something about the affordable housing
mix um there is nothing i know it's only
an outline planning permission but we
have in
some other recent outline planning
commissions we have
um sort of got a guideline of what the
market housing mix is and i just
wondered if there had been any um
anything to do with um
you know market housing mix and whether
um the applicant is
is willing to fix that now
to make it more more certain for the
um whoever takes it on to build it and
more certain for stow market and their
housing needs um
the
discussions have centered on the
affordable housing mix admittedly
um because we've had detail because
obviously that that
that element of it goes into the
viability issues generally but again um
we're mindful of that and we've
suggested that a condition be imposed so
that the actual details of the mix can
form part of the reserve matters
application and that's something that
colleagues in our strategic housing team
would be out to advise us on as well as
well as the affordable housing mix so we
are looking to
um
consider that in more detail through
condition but we're not we haven't had
those level of discussions
at this stage
council field
thank you a couple of questions
firstly notice the site has only a
single entrance for 300 houses
most applications we've seen
seem to consider 150 or they're about
the maximum for a single entrance
presumably that's because the diapers
farm connection
but we just essentially been told
there's no guarantee that will come
forward and no guarantee it will provide
any um
any access
and i know there's no
emergency access of any type into this
estate
so could you
comment on that please
um i think you're right counselor the um
the point of access is a single point of
access
it doesn't
meet with
the um
objection of the highway authority
and
i think i mean i don't know but i think
that is on the basis as you say that the
um
the
diapers farm site would have a
continuation of the access leading
through
both sites so there would be two points
of access
at the end
and
in terms of the
the um sorry the the safety of the
vehicles getting in for the hot um
getting into the site um
ambulances and things
again um that's a that's an element that
they've had to consider as part of this
and they've not advised us that they've
got a problem with the arrangement that
he's shown so
we've relied on the the advice that
we've been given in relation to that
aspect of it
it seems surprising we seem to have two
things that are linked together i can't
see um
you know
if we approve this one then to make it
safe we have to approve the dough as
farmer uh application therefore we're
sort of fattering our judgment are we
not
it seems
that there should be uh some clarity on
that
just the fact that highways haven't uh
have made some assumptions and on that
basis not raised any queries doesn't
seem adequate
well i think that it's clear from the
development brief and this the
stone market area action plan that the
achievement of link across is important
that that actually links
newton mode to stowe upland road um and
therefore
that is a requirement of development
that's something we can seek to secure
i i suspect that um
if
uh something came in that didn't show a
link through then we're not likely to
approve it
um we couldn't consider it as a as an
appropriate development if it's not
showing
the means of a physical blink from one
side to the other
you will have approved this one already
we will have approved this application
in outline already
so can i can i just follow up from
john's point so is there anything that
we could condition to say that the first
house can't be occupied until the link
road is built through the other side
um well i think that in terms of the the
nature of the application you have
before you as an outline proposal so the
difficulty is
um
the intention to provide a link is is
shown on an illustrative plan and in the
supporting information it's acknowledged
we can't actually i don't think
condition the means or the form of
access because it's not the application
isn't at that stage we're not being
asked to consider a road layout as such
all we're being asked to consider is the
access onto newton road
so i think that the intention would be
that the details of the layout would
include the access through to diapers
farm and at that point
we can actually say that
you know that whatever development takes
place on on this part of the site on the
ashes farm site
as chair was suggesting there'd be a
trigger point within there to say that
that link's got to be provided before
the
when does that come when it comes back
to reserve
when would we be able to get that
condition
um i think what
i think what people are saying is in
theory they could just build 300 houses
on this one road
and not build diapers then then we're
suddenly
they could we would give
planning permission if we grant planning
permit outline planning permission now
we grant provide up to up to 300 units
on the site but we're not granting
anything in terms of the detail of that
so we're not they couldn't i think they
were not in a position they could just
crack on and start they would actually
have to go for the second stage of the
reserve matters
and at that stage i think we were able
then to consider the the layout and
everything good yeah it would be good if
phil and israel and jumping in the
officers could look at some condition
that ties those things together
adequately can i ask one other question
then i hope this is uh allowable it's an
issue of
the viability i know that um the
it's difficult to see what what on this
site makes it makes it impossible to
deliver our policy number of affordable
houses it's 20 is 15 or so lower than we
normally
accept
but one aspect is the uh the junction
with the
b215 the the proposed new roundabout or
whatever is uh comes forward
and that's costed at about
750k
and
the
commitment seems to be that that will go
ahead however many sites are approved so
i was really looking for
is that a significant impact on on
viability
and if so what's the mechanism that
perhaps adjusts the
number of affordable houses or whatever
should that roundabout cost be actually
shared two or three ways rather than
loaded entirely on one of the sites
um the viability assessment is based or
the
the required roundabout works and the
apportionment if that's the right word
is
based on the amount of units that are
being applied for so therefore 300
the the total cost of the roundabout
which is estimated as you say to be 750
000 pounds
the apportionment is based on the
number of units that the application
would seek to achieve so in this case up
to 300 so it's a pro rata payment which
has been factored into the
viability
so the cost is borne by the developer
or the three developers
if there are three developers or if
there's not two developers on on the
site that's actually allocate the sites
are actually allocated in the local plan
at this point in time so the third one
isn't
but there's three developers who
potentially be contributing
um it could be that one developer has to
i'd say the developer who is providing
the development of 300 units plays
pays that proportion towards the works
but the others would have to provide
their their elements of it but that
proportionality has been considered as
part of the um
assessment viability on the site thank
you but that implies that if the either
of the other two developments don't go
forward then neither do the road
junction improvements because there
won't be enough cash for them
well i think that in any event um
there will be a trigger point that's
within this development
sorry within the memorandum of
understanding which is a clear
requirement that these wake these works
take place when a certain level of
occupancy takes place so there will be
um as far as we're concerned um
sufficient weight behind that to ensure
that the works do take place but
everyone's coming
thank you yes i'm a bit late to this
because i've had my head slightly in a
related question following on from
council man sales point just so i
understand the question here
we're talking about trying to make sure
the allocation as a whole is delivered
so it's a complete package is that
effectively what we're trying to secure
by this conversation is that do i have
that right
i was initially questioning the
viability
and whether the
sharing of these
costs of this particular development
impacts the viability of this site and
and therefore the affordable delivery
i'm told no it doesn't the
amount of money is dependent on the
number of units delivered which i
understand that i'm then seeking to
ensure how can we guarantee that the
road junction improvements will go
through
if less than the
300 houses a year and whatever number is
250 houses on diaper farm and if
if there's some
if the diapers farm
development does not go ahead or the
third one does not go ahead how do we
ensure there's adequate funding to get
this road development uh
implemented
does the county council accept the
additional cost that it will have to
find
thank you casterfield i think i
understand the question now so um we're
all hostage to the market with this as
we are with most
developments so
there is a risk that sites still
and i'll come back to that in a second
obviously the road junction improvements
are only needed once you have a harm so
there has to be a timing question to
this
and logically once you get past a
certain number of dwellings you get to a
point where
you have foresee that the scheme will be
needed to mitigate the harm that will
foreseeably follow along so there's
there's a kind of phasing and timing
question that ultimately is
is a matter of um
forecasting on the part of county
highways to get
to a point where what are the works that
they need to do when do they need to
design them and effectively at what
point do you anticipate the direction of
travel where the development takes you
there
now
you can anticipate that to some degree
within the section 106 you can never
absolutely guarantee what will happen
but if a site stalls
then you would hope that you've got to a
point where sufficient funds have been
taken
to ensure that you are planning for the
mitigation before you actually get to
the point you
allow a situation to become a problem
and then mitigate it you try to to
anticipate and deliver as you go
um
and you know we are in a situation where
if the housing market stalls
we could see the site
stalled accordingly that's not
impossible it's taken this long
to get
the
allocation to a position where we have
something to put in front of committee
i think the question of whether zone 2
and 3 come forward
we have an application on the table i
don't see that there's any loss of heat
in the housing market but i wouldn't
rule it out so i would anticipate that
this is about programming
on a highways point to ensure that the
contributions
are received at a point in time that
does not compromise viability but make
sure funds are available in good time to
anticipate the harm when it arises
so those things are important
um
i i think within the section 106 heads
of terms that we have and i don't have
them literally in front of me i'll need
just to refer to them
whichever page i've got open
um we
[Music]
i think we can probably we we have a
traffic regulation order contribution as
part of this um brad but what you
described around the memorandum of
understanding would need to be an
additional
head of turn to this section 106
presumably
so probably if if we give you some words
around that and spend a little time
adding to that
then
we can give you some but i would
probably say unfortunately not absolute
certainty because we are all going to be
hostage to the market
and if a site stalls we are in a very
different situation
and can i come back to councilman
question
so councillor mansell had talked about
the connectivity pedestrian cycles
vehicles between sites again we're
dealing with two different applicants
two different owners
we have to try and make sense of this
what i would suggest as a solution is a
section 106 obligation
to ensure that we have a scheme that
manages the delivery of that public
pedestrian cycle and vehicular access
between this application site
and what's referred to as zone two and
three in the development brief onto snow
upland road so that we can ensure that
as far as possible access is available
in a phased way relative to the delivery
of the development
if only part of this site is developed i
wouldn't wish to
prescribe
in this committee meeting
at what point those triggers occur
but as we're talking it occurs to me
that it would also be sensible to have a
fullback such that if the development
stalls
there is some provision made to
anticipate that
before we've delivered 300 houses here
and
that we look to achieve something so
that we cannot guarantee zones 3 and
zones 2 will be delivered
but what we can do is make sure that
at worst the fullback being not later
than uh a period of time after
construction ceases
that there is access available up to the
boundary at least for pedestrians and
footpaths so those onward connections
can be made
so a little bit more work needed on that
and probably to pick up cancer fields
point
but there is a mechanism which is
effectively an additional section 106
obligation
thank you very much okay that clears
that up and i've still got lots of fans
i've got council masters and then mayor
then ebern
yeah yeah thank thank you chair yeah i
think i mean i i welcome the the the
progress
um
that mister i just say we're not in
debate now yes
i welcome that that's going on and we'll
be interested to hear more about it
because obviously it refers back to my
first question
about the the two sites etc but i i'm
wondering
firstly
there is um a note on page 20
that strategic housing um final views
were not available etc have we actually
heard
all the
bits of that has that trickled out
gradually um
already in what's been said about the um
the affordables and so forth and there
was a question about the market housing
um have we had that update
but then turning to the
the connectivity etc i i've i'd really
it would really be helpful to see
one map that shows us
the
um the vehicle
impact points these junctions
in in relation to these three sites
um to just be absolutely clear where
they are so we can sort of see whether
you know the relative pressures but also
the essentially the same point about the
the pedestrian and cycle
network that will result
um
because i'm
quite anxious
that in the real world
there are differences
yeah are we can we see something that
will show
whether the
um
the path beside the allotments is going
to turn into a desire line for
pedestrians and and cyclists or not
because i can't get that in my head at
the moment
or is that possibly something that has
to wait to reserve matters maybe it is
but i i don't have a clarity on either
of those okay the vehicles is now
possibly the walking is later but
thanks
yes cancer the the current position in
relation to strategic housing team is as
set out on the um
uh
table paper
that is their current position um which
if you look under the background section
um
that that basically sets out what they
think is most appropriate which is
that's on an 18
provision across the site 75-25
that isn't finally established with the
developer yet
hence the the change in the
recommendation so we still got to have a
discussion but that is the current
position
on that thing
um
with regard to the access as i said that
is shown as part of the the red line
application site so it's assumed to be
under the ownership of control of the
applicant at the time the application is
made
but it's not being proposed under their
plans at this stage to have any
pedestrian or cycle
access leading from the site down that
access and onto newton road
what they are actually suggesting is
that the
the access
um if you could
sorry could you put the um presentation
up again please
thank you
oh i'm sorry i'll just get to the right
slide
yes this is the illustrative master plan
that submitted as part of the planning
application
um
and the the the access i was just
talking about there which is shown as
part of the red line but it's not
excuse me it's not actually shown as
providing a footpath or a
cycleway link through to newton road at
that point and what is actually being
proposed
is an access through at this point
from of the site which actually goes
through to the public right of way which
leads on to stone upland road
so there's there's there's indicative
links
or illustrative links
on that particular point
the means of access
to the site is up here
and on the
i'll go back to
oh i'll go wrong way sorry
yes and the um
i apologize for the scale but the the
junction we're talking about
you stole upland is there
yes
that's
approximately on this if i go to the
next one um that's that's a
slightly larger scale
um john's correct in his where it is
that's where it is
that's correct yes which which is not
within the red line but it's there
already it'll be at that point there so
i suppose
that that seems reasonably satisfactory
to answer my question provided it is of
an adequate width and quality
no proposal anywhere to improve that
the works to
the works within the site the
application site would would be in
accordance with the requirement
i think if you're saying that the the
works to the prowl outside of the site
um if there were proposed works to the
prowl outside of the site they would
have to be they'll be controllable by
the highway authority
so they would have to control those
works because they're not claiming
ownership of that part of the they don't
own that piece of land the the prowl
runs through but they want to link into
it so
um yeah if there's anything actually
within that proud land then i think
that's within the remit of the highway
authority to control thank you but they
haven't asked for the money to do
anything with it
sorry john have they asked for any money
to do anything with that
right of way
in
the higher authority yeah no no
thank you okay councilman there was next
thanks chip um
back to the b treble one five and a one
one two zero i'm afraid um
the district the town council has not
identified that
b road as being
issues with road safety
i'm concerned that
these works and proposed works may never
be come to fruition
is there any way we can condition them
earlier in
the build
for example um
the
developer only has to provide a plan
before um the first occupation you've
got all the construction traffic coming
in um and
notwithstanding the points made by
council of field
i'm not really reassured by the fact
that um the approved highway works will
be delivered at a point before the
impact of the highway network becomes
severe
in my three and a half years on this
committee
highways have never to my knowledge said
anything severe and i'm unaware of a
definition of what severe is
so if we were able to condition those
those works prior to the start on site
we would ensure that the the works would
be delivered they'd be delivered in a
timely way and be able to deal with some
of the construction traffic as well can
you give some thought to that for when
we get into debate
yes
because i think there's a common theme
here it's that same with the footpaths
and yeah it's how we link all that up
um
counselor e burn you want to come back
or something
um thank you very much chair and um
thank you councilman i was going to
follow that up as well
but my other point on highways was also
the the
traffic going along spring roads my
concern is that when people come out of
this
prior to diapers farm being developed
because originally we thought they'd
both come together and traffic would
therefore have a different way at the
moment traffic from this site will only
come out onto newton road and unless
they want to travel to old newton
they're going to go through
stone market
center basically and potentially down
spring row has there been any
consideration of mitigation against
congestion along spring roads that's
already a very narrow road with parking
all the way along one side
thank you
well i think that the
[Music]
as i said in the report the
um application is accompanied by a
traffic assessment
um we have relied on the advice of the
highway authority in this case as we
normally do
and they have assessed that the highway
authority and highways england
have
assessed
the information in the traffic
assessment um and
the elements that are proposed have not
met with their objection apart from that
one um
junction alteration that i mentioned in
my presentation
and the conditions that the highway
authority are seeking to impose as part
of this application
um
are
listed um
within the agenda and page 71
but that element
that you just described cancer has not
been mentioned as an issue by them so
i'm not sure there's much more concern
that particular point okay that's right
thank you very much okay we've got one
more question then we're going to move
on councillor mansell
uh thank you i've got two uh points i'd
just like to
query
um
one is i've got
i've opened up the design and access
statement
and on page 16 of the dna
there is a sort of plan of the site
which claims
that that track beside the
allotments has got a label on it saying
four meter emergency access
and i just wonder whether you haven't
mentioned it is that an emergency access
or not
um my other query related to uh council
matheson's comments about the
uh cycle pedestrian link onto the little
track next to uplands
because that track is currently a public
footpath
so any cyclists coming out of this new
development at that cycle pedestrian
link that is proposed
will then have to cycle down
a public footpath which i believe is
illegal lots of people do it but
um maybe we should put something in
about upgrading that particular bit of
the footpath to a bridal way status so
that it's not illegal to cycle down it
thank you
we can hold that back again for debate
and bradley if you can give some thought
um yes on the
the emergency link um i haven't
mentioned that in my report because i
didn't underst that wasn't my
understanding that that was being
offered as an emergency link through
um i'm looking at the the illustrative
plan there's nothing on there to suggest
which is i've relied on
um there's nothing to suggest that that
is the case as part of that um it's just
shown as land edge red
um we have the applicant's agent here so
that may be something asking that
question when they come
it's on the dna okay
um with regards to the the prowl i
understand the point um there is
obviously the allocation of cycle ways
within star upland themselves but i do
take the point about that that stretch
um linking the site to
the cycleway provision in stockholm road
and um
i think that's something again that we
can
consider as part of taking away on um
you know as a comment to come back to
the upgrading
okay good well thank you and we're now
going to move on um so uh we don't have
um
the parish or town council no we don't
have an objector we don't have a
supporter we have the agent
uh andrew brooks so um
happy to hand over to you and if you can
keep the three minutes please over to
you when you're ready
good morning members
firstly i'd like to thank officers for
the detailed report you have before you
and to endorse the recommendation for
approval of this application
stow market is in the top tier of the
settlement hierarchy benefiting from an
extensive range of services and
facilities making it the main focus for
development in the district
the sustainable location of the
application sites immediately adjacent
to the town meant that it was adopted in
the stone market area action plan back
in 2013.
in 2016 the council published the ash's
farm development brief confirming the
site's capacity of 300 dwellings as such
the principle of residential development
of the site has been acceptable for
almost 10 years
the proposed scheme will deliver a
highly sustainable residential
development which will have positive
social economic and environmental
benefits also assisting the council in
delivering its development plan aims
whilst the scheme is made in outline
only the illustrative master plan
demonstrates how the site can be
developed delivered in accordance with
the development
brief economic growth will be created
through construction activities
and when occupied residents will
contribute to local expenditure
socially the development will provide a
range of homes including affordable
homes with smaller properties as well as
family housing
pedestrian and cycle links will be
provided connecting to the existing
public right-of-way
new footpaths and crossings will be
created along newton road providing safe
and convenient access to the town centre
as well as the formalization of 18
parking spaces along newton road
additional highway upgrades as set out
earlier by mr heifer will be secured
including improvements to the b triple 1
5 a
11 20 junction at stokeland mitigating
impacts of the development and easing
congestion
finally in terms of environmental
benefits the development will provide
new public open space including
children's equipped play serving both
future and existing nearby residents
areas of informal open space and
sustainable drainage are proposed to the
west of the sites including the
retention of the existing woodland with
additional informal open space provided
on the parcel of land west of newton
road
a full suite of financial contributions
for infrastructure needs have been
requested and will be secured through
the section 106
including education
libraries waste healthcare and towards a
bus service to serve the site
in summary officers have concluded that
the application accords with the
development plan and that there are no
material considerations which indicate a
decision should be taken contrary to
their recommendation to approve
i call on you to recognize the
significant merits of this sustainable
scheme on an allocated site and urge you
to support the proposals and grant
planning permission thank you
thanks very much
okay um
questions remembers i guess the one from
all of us is you've heard
you would have heard the committee
asking officers about the links through
to the other site in terms of highways
in terms of rolling out the highways
changes in terms of footpath cycleway
links
um is there any sort of anything
reassuring you can give us on that or or
do you know it'd just be interesting
your thoughts
sure
um with regards to um the design like
sustainment which mentioned the
emergency access uh i think that was an
initially
um an aspiration just to provide a
secondary access um but after discussion
with the highway authority um they they
didn't want that to be provided so it's
actually shown as a drainage route on
the updated master plan
um so so that deals with that
point
and the highway authority response to
the single point of access they actually
i think um that was actually in
accepting
irrespective of the link through so
um
i think we've just perhaps had a
miscommunication on what the the highway
authority have said that they're happy
for it to be a single point of access
for the 300 unit scheme there was
negotiation on that early on in the
application uh
determination consideration so
they were happy with that obviously this
is an outline scheme so we haven't fully
detailed we've provided an illustrative
plan but we haven't provided the full
detail of how that road would link
through to the adjacent site but yes
that is in the development brief and
there's the intention to link to that
site okay thank you very much any
further questions yes councilman
thank you for your clarification about
the uh the um
emergency access on the dna um
would you consider
making the proposed uh path that you're
going to put on the western side of
newton road between the junction of
spring road and the
a14 bridge would you consider making
that a three meter wide path so that it
is suitable for cycles
and that is on your
with presumably that is within your
redline area thank you
thank you councillor and obviously the
proposals um haven't included for that
um it's not something that the highway
authority requested um so it's not been
it's not been requested or required by
them um that wouldn't mean to say we
wouldn't but it's it's just not on the
table today
so so so if if this um application
application is approved
is there any scope for maneuver you'd
say highways haven't requested it that
doesn't mean you can't do it so
will you consider it
it's it's something we're not opposed to
um but it as i say it's all of the
highway
proposals for the scheme have been
assessed by the ohio authority and they
haven't been required i think it's up to
the committee to determine if you want
to condition it or not
okay
yeah phillip
just just on that point i don't think
you could really do it with a condition
because what you're talking about is
upgrading a bridal way that's going to
be a process
okay
talking about the path that they're
creating on the western side of newton
road it's currently put down as two
meters wide
because that's what highways have said
that's all they need i'm just saying
could we have more but the answer
clearly is no
okay any other questions
no okay so we'll move on um we now have
a statement from councillor carter and
obviously we have uh
councilman do you want to go first or
second
one
should i read out councillor carter's
comments first okay so this is from
councillor carter who can't be here
today
i wish to start by touching on the fact
that this is a development on a known
flood plain recognised by locals as a
wildlife hot spot of sorts and given the
council's motions on biodiversity and
climate crisis already presents
precisely the type of habitat we should
be seeking to improve upon and protect
as i highly endorse this and second
of the objections made by stone market
town council stone market society and i
would like to highlight the following
issues the development is on the
floodplain is as dubious as to the
measures suggested to mitigate this
handling the increase in flooding due to
abhorrent weather as predicted due to
climate change let alone the increased
pressure of 300 properties to be placed
on top two the prospects of the
inability of minor roads to cope with
the increasing demands leads to my
concern
should the flood prevention measures
also fail the road access itself being
within the current floodplain
could leave residents cut off from
access to emergency services
the stone market society has also
commented on the impact of the local
amenities and infrastructure still
health doctor surgery is already
operating to capacity
cedars primary school was running at 98
capacity in 2019 and the newly built
grace cook school is already fully
subscribed
only one current dentist surgery is
accepting new adults nhs patients
seal is all well and good yet we can
hardly look to it to solve the problems
residents are facing now let's alone
with the additional strain 300 houses
would undoubtedly make
councilman over to you
much uh thank you i might be able to
provide some clarification to members
regarding the diecast farm estate i know
appreciate you can't comment on that
today but it might be worthwhile
mentioning this we did have a
presentation a few months ago at stone
market town council planning from the
developer for that site and they are
proposing to have the road access coming
halfway up the stow upland road
so it would not come out at the
roundabout at the junction with mortimer
road but halfway through halfway up the
road
and that's what we saw on the plans that
were actually presented to us at that
particular time
the other thing that's mentioned in the
report in power 4.2 which is quite
interesting about the proposed
development may be accessed by either a
new or extended bus service well there's
very few buses at present go along
newton road and no buses actually go up
the still upland road because all the
buses actually go up uh navigation
approach and baltimore road towards
stowe upland
so whether that will be a viable option
i i very much doubt uh in that respect
newton road is a very narrow road and
currently only has a payment on one side
of the road as we have actually seen in
in the actual presentation and as you
saw so in the presentation a lot of the
residents park their vehicles outside
their properties making it even narrower
i'm particularly concerned about the
junction with the
b115 and the newton row it's like a
little mini roundabout there that does
get very congested at certain times
particularly
when the uh crossing is closed for
trains to go through and i've witnessed
this on many many occasions and it can
hold up the traffic for some
considerable time so this development
with potential with 300 properties and
the number of vehicles going through
there will only sort of make that
situation a lot worse
however there are some really sort of
positive things with this application
like i do actually fully support the
three character areas that are mentioned
in the report the main street with a
tree-lined spine route the avenue core
and overlap between the main street and
the green frontage and the green front
is reflecting the character of the
surrounding landscape and i'm also
pleased to see that as many trees as
possible will be retained and this is
very important obviously with climate
change etc i fully support a proper
construction management plan for the
site so the inconvenience to current
residents in newton road is kept to a
minimum during any construction if if
the application is approved
but my main concern a is for congestion
around the junction between newton road
and the stow upland road
and although not technically related to
the planning application my main
concerns and severe reservations concern
that cedars park primary school is
currently full
i understand that stow upland primary
school is also full the new grace cook
academy as mentioned by council carter
is also fully subscribed the result is
that children will have to travel
further to school which will on balance
the probabilities mean more cars on the
already narrow road causing further
congestion and believe me it does get
congested down there at that time of the
day
neither stow health nor coombs forward
surgeries have the capacity for
additional growth resulting from this
development the town desperately needs
new primary health care facilities
although even if this was built there is
a problem recruiting general
practitioners etc and i believe there is
one dentist currently taking on new nhs
patients in the town
so in conclusion although there are some
very positive aspects to this
application i have major concerns about
the school and health position to number
two and in view of this i am able to
give my support to this application
and this is the sort of message we're
getting from residents is about the
health care schools etc so that's really
really important to the residents which
i think needs to be considered thank you
very much jeff happy to take any
questions
thank you council food
thank you just uh on the issue of stone
health i thought the analysis in our
papers implies that it has still
capacity
42
i i don't remember the numbers without
looking them up but i just
said uh there are two health facilities
one of them has capacity the other
lacks capacity and there was a small
balancing number yeah
the situation with stow health and what
we've heard in the past they do have
actual spare rooms upstairs on the top
floor to accommodate up to five gps
however they just cannot recruit gps at
the moment so at the moment they are
sort of basically at capacity
can i ask a question of bradley so um
you've heard the ward member talk about
edu primary schools but there's a
there's a contribution of over one and a
half million pounds just for the primary
school so do we know is that to towards
new places is it towards extending the
existing school do you know what that
one and a half million is for
sorry jack yes the um
the
mitigation um includes a setting for
early years in other words land
uh which you'd have noted but the rest
of it is contributions to
improved existing facilities so it could
be building places at existing schools
yeah
thank you council pass me yeah um thanks
matthew i just related to what dave was
saying about healthcare i'm actually
rather concerned about this because if
you look at page so i forgot my glasses
page 55
um
paragraph 4.1 it actually says existing
gp practices do not have capacity
to accommodate the additional growth
now i'm puzzled what on earth the nhs is
up to here because this just doesn't
make sense
um
and i can't see how this is all going to
fit together and this is an ongoing
problem throughout the district i know
we've got to look just at this
application
yeah but
there's the capital required to develop
contributions was former proportion
required funding
to absorb the capacity and generated by
this development
so are they really saying that 172 000
quids are going to sort that all out
because i find that extraordinary
i don't know i get that that's why i
raised the question earlier but picking
up on dave's point i mean you're getting
700 extra residents
you read bullet points 6.5 in essence
yes yes this does mean
for us to deliver that doesn't mean
they're right of course
and we know that with highway and that
is seriously i think it's i'm a bit
concerned about that council he burned
the councilman so these are
um
thank you chair i'm grateful to
councillor miller for mentioning the
buses because i've forgotten to raise
that that the highway statement says
that the where the nearest bus stops are
that's true there are bus stops there
but there are no buses
so could we have confirmation of the
of how these the people on this site are
going to travel by public transport and
where their nearest
access to a bus is thank you
yes the um as
councilman pointed out there isn't a bus
service that runs through whether the
site is obviously undeveloped at the
moment there's a bus service that goes
up um snow upland road there isn't one
up newton road as far as i'm aware
if i may chair the buses from stone
market to stop and go via cedars park
but in terms of the um
thank you for clarification but in terms
of the um
the requirements um it is a requirement
in the
sap and also in the development brief
that a bus service is
provided
or an existing bus service is improved
in order to serve this site
the design of the
main road through the site would be in
order to accept
a bus
and similarly on the
diapers farm site so there would be
potentially bus penetration
if that was attractive to a service
operator
and highway so yes highway authority
have confirmed that the fund
for that would enable them to
look at how that service provision would
take place so
we would look to make sure that there
was infrastructure in place
as part of that
the way the site works as i say in terms
of detail would be looked at reserved
matter stage but through this
um at this level we can actually secure
a contribution a pro rata contribution
to that um
to that requirement we're not going to
get any beyond that i think yeah
so you're saying we could require a
contribution to get an actual bus
because at the moment the distance from
the site to a
to be able to physically get on a bus if
we i don't know how many meters 500
meters
at least
700 meters so you're not
i'm not able to give sorry council i'm
not able to give you details as a
service provision
i'm not able to do that because what
what the county have asked for is a
contribution in order for them to
actually
look at that service provision
themselves
we did
consider at one point whether it be
appropriate for
the developer to in effect buy a service
similarly with the um the diapers farm
site but the county were clear that they
they wanted the contribution so we've
we've looked to pursue that on their
behalf thank you thanks councilman
um i just want to clarify whilst we're
discussing all of these um sums of money
that various infrastructure providers
have asked for that this is all coming
out of section 106 because this is in
stone market and there is no cil
is that am i correct there
all these contributions that we're
talking about for the infrastructure
providers they are coming out of a
section 106 agreement and there is no
sill because this is in stone market um
can you just confirm
that is the case
that is correct yep there is no seal
payable on this site at present
council humphreys
mr thank you and um so just for
clarification um
this will bring money towards a possible
bus there's no guarantee of it they'll
just look at it and you can't improve
the current bus service because there
isn't one
so there's no guarantee of a bus service
at all isn't that true
that all depends on the viability of the
amount of housing that comes in with
it's the same with every bus route in
the county
yeah but isn't it true it's not
guaranteed it'll be a bus service that's
correct doesn't it
um well as far as i can answer that
question um
we're securing a contribution
the requirement to secure the service
would rest with the
the county council
and we
are doing what we've been asked to do
which is basically secure a contribution
to that service as part of it which was
a requirement of the um
development brief and the sap
so i think what we're trying to do is in
accordance with the requirements i
understand the point that's being made
and i wish i could actually sit here and
say exactly how that service is going to
work
and what buses will be used but i think
we have to try to
free future proof as much as possible in
terms of um
at least securing some level of service
bearing in mind the overall cohort on
this side is 500 and
something units
okay any other
yes counselor matt and then we're going
to go into debate
yeah the the um i wanted to ask um
councilman muller when you had the
presentation about the diaper site
um did was there any hint that there
might be land um kept aside for nhs
provisions i mean the the access
problems to violet hill are well known
and can only get worse
uh the answer that is no
we can only look at what's before us
today john
okay so i'm going to move us on
now uh to discuss debate and come to a
conclusion
uh councillor humphreys
thank you mr chair um i too like
councillor miller acknowledged this is
part of the stone market area action
plan is
designated for development and actually
i do like certain elements of it so so
i'm not totally against this but i have
to go down the transport route to be
honest with you so if i go to the town
council comments it's all about really
that
concern about the highways and transport
grounds recognizes concerns that exist
local community about proposals and
again wholly unsatisfactory because a
detrimental effect upon the immunity of
local residents implications of road
safety along the b115 the capacity of
this minor road it's capacity that i
want to go on to so i'm not an expert on
safety i think highways are we got to
accept that they brought up no safety
issues but i do need to talk about
capacity that road is narrow it's
difficult now
let alone when we got three or more
residents and it's really nice that we
can turn right and go to new well what's
up there why would people drive that way
they're driving to town the town's
already massively congested from that
area coming down still upland road and
newton road and it's really nicely
making improvements or proposed
improvements to stow upland to that
junction that takes me to startland but
what about improvements to stone market
that's where we actually need the
required
improvements so i've got a real issue
with it and when i go into the planning
document
you've already mentioned it actually
where it talks about
[Music]
developments you'd only refused
prevented or refused on highways grounds
if there would be an unacceptable impact
on highway safety all the residential
cumulative impacts on the road network
would be severe i come back to council
mayor's point what's the definition
severe
because i've looked and looked and
looked and i can't find it i've got some
experts in the room so hopefully you'll
have the answers to give me that
definition
but i can tell you now as a resident
stone market it's already severe in my
opinion and the opinion of many
residents and we're going to compound
that now by putting another 300
residence vehicles up and down newton
road i just don't get it and i
understand that if the other development
came on we have another um entrance or
exit or access to sterling road that
would mitigate some of this but at the
moment it doesn't at all it just
compounds the problem so under the
national planning
document that point really
i believe is relevant it is a
significant impact in terms of capacity
and congestion
i'm not consuming the highway safety uh
it says there can be cost effectively
mitigated to an acceptable level well
unless you're going to widen the road i
can't say that it is
so and i see nothing within this plan at
all that would allow
you to mitigate against that in
increased
cumulative effect of capacity on those
roads
and that's my point
and because of that i can't support this
because of that cumulative effect
um thank you chair um i appreciate a
huge amount of work has gone into this
from both planners and agents and
everybody involved and that this site
has been
um in the offing for
many many years
15 or so i suspect
i've i've have do have however a lot of
concerns that i just think haven't been
kind of
wrapped up fully enough
in terms of of us you know getting
certainty over various things and and my
list includes um the open space
provision particularly to the north of
the site
i'm allowing a break with
stone market and still upland
the housing mix we
you know i'd like us to be able to put
forward something about the market
housing mix in terms of what stone
market needs but we don't have that
information i'm not talking affordable
housing i mean the market housing um the
access for pedestrians and cyclists i
mean we can look at a map and suggest
where we might want it to be but it
doesn't seem just doesn't seem clear
enough to me or doesn't have any
certainty
um the the the lack of bus services at
the moment i can't see the travel plan
contribution or whatever contribution is
being enough to um
set up because it will be setting up a
bus service
um and then there's the sort of policy
issues in terms of the changes since
um that we've seen in the area since the
development brief was done and
particularly the changes we've seen in
the area since state market air reaction
plan because there's been a huge amount
of development since which wouldn't you
know obviously wasn't considered at the
time of either of those two documents so
i think for me chair there's just a lot
of uncertainty and i just don't feel
confident
personally to make a decision when i've
got so many outstanding questions thank
you
councilman
uh thank you
i too feel like counselor ebon that
there's just too many
unknowns here
and i i would just like to say that i
know this
application is not unique but we yet
again seem to be hostage
to our colleagues in highways
and whatever they say is
necessary
is all we get and and i really think we
ought to be doing better than the bare
minimum
now to my mind
putting that two meter footpath on the
side of
newton road when you've got the land
next to it is a missed opportunity
um and okay highways haven't asked for
it but that doesn't mean it can't be
done um and
time and time again
highway say oh yes the capacity at this
junction is fine we'll just do x y zed
and we can mitigate it
and every time the locals
think otherwise
now i'm not saying that the locals are
traffic experts but they're the ones who
are there every day
and if they think i mean if they think
there is a queue and a difficulty
getting out of that junction they know
about it uh and and we just always seem
to be um hostage to highways um
and and i i just think that we ought to
be looking at things in a more strategic
view if we want if we really really
really want to get traffic off the road
we need to make it easier for people to
walk and cycle to where they need to get
to and put buses on
um and that just never seems to happen
it's always the bare minimum on the
highway
um and um the local rest of the existing
residents have to put up with more
traffic on an inadequate network um
and i i i mean i know all these things
can't be solved with this one planning
application but i like um counselor e
burn i think there are so many unknowns
it just doesn't feel like this
um application is ready uh
recently we've had a number of outline
applications which have got quite a lot
more detail about the links
uh about the housing mix and all that
and we haven't got any of that there's
just too many things that we're not too
sure about
so i don't think i can be supporting
this application that's the password
um yeah thanks matthew well i've
listened to what everybody's had to say
and of course the applicants in the room
i think some of these questions do need
to be answered so i wonder whether it
might be suited when i'd be prepared to
do this if i could get some support to
defer the decision on this because a
heck of a lot of work has gone into this
but these are very serious questions
that do need some answers
and i think particularly on the highways
we've got a whole long list of things
that we're concerned about i know it's
an outline application but i do think we
need more information on this in order
to make an informed decision we've got
to work with what local people want it
isn't just about what planning
inspectorates and other people we are
elected as we all say to represent local
people i think there may well be a way
through with all this but i do think
we've got to have much more information
on this the highways i mean that road um
going up to old newton i mean i know it
well it is very narrow it's difficult
with people parking on there
anyway if you put 300 houses there's
probably going to be
600 cars or 500 cars whether people
agree with it or not we have to look at
the reality
um and junction improvements maybe
there's a traffic management plan or
something i don't know but we would need
to know that before we could say in
principle so
i'm going to formally propose due to the
lack of information
okay
okay well that's been proposed and
seconded a couple of other people may
want to be councillor field you had your
hand up
yeah thank you um
that answers it all i i
feel that this
development is in in accordance with a
development brief
and therefore there's some considerable
justification for it
and there is always a need for
additional housing so on those basis i'm
fairly happy with it
but i do
and i would say there are a number of
issues always that residents
rise which are very genuine concern but
can be solved with a bit of effort and a
bit of
cash but there are issues with this
development which i just don't like at
all
i the the one that really sticks in mind
is this issue of a single access serving
300 houses i've sat in this committee
and rejected
developments of around 150 houses that
have only a single access
and we understand that highways are
assuming that certain other developments
will come along that are also within the
development brief
and that that will resolve those
problems but that seems to be an
inadequate response we should be very
clear that there's a maximum
a number of houses we can serve through
a single access and should additional
access be provided then we will be happy
for the
numbers to
expand but not just a blanket approval
assuming something that is far from
certain may occur
that's true of the transporters cancer
humphries outline doing the same thing
we're making assumptions that certain
facilities will be provided they
probably won't
um and the issue of the junction the
road junction would be treble 1-5 is
another one of those issues where um
we we have a sort of a
um
might believe solution a solution that
may occur but highly probably won't
occur to an issue which really impacts a
whole load of residents i don't know how
many times i've sat here and heard
people
raising the issues of congestion in
stone market particularly at that
junction
so
i would agree with the thought that
there are
um a number of issues which really need
resolving we need to be absolutely
certain that the basic the decision
we're making is on the basis of fact of
things that actually occur not just
imagination
um so um
yes there's too many uncertainties
i i'm inclined to agree with with
councillor password humphreys that a
deferment would be a solution um let's
get these things fixed i don't feel
confident
in
advocating total rejection against the
thought that
there is a development brief with which
lawsuit
then we'll go to the vote
yeah i i mean i've
i have a particular ownership of the
stone market reaction plan i've been
very involved in the work for several
years before that was produced
and um
you know it does look to
doing a good quality development
for the town
as a whole and so on and so on and at
the moment as members have said you know
this is this is not
not contributing well to that and i
would just
say to those that have been expressing
the concerns about the bus service and
how it might or might not be provided
how was the bus service provided to the
chilton lays development in my ward
and the answer is by actually pinching
the existing bits out of out of the
service in order to get the same circuit
time
including children lays at the expense
of edmonds road and and thermia drive
and
somewhere else i think so
we can't keep pinching bits of bus
service and taking that and handing over
the money that isn't actually delivering
what's needed which is more bus services
and that helps with the congestion issue
which i can only agree with others about
okay did anyone know yes cousin there
sorry she has to delay just a little bit
um
i agree with it i think the vast
majority of what's been said
i think
particularly with the ccg
statement they want 172 000 pounds
i'd like to challenge these experts we
accept their word we accept what
highways say and we have to roll over
and yet we know
in all of our awards that surgeries are
over prescribed the dentistry is not
available
is there scope for us to go back and say
more information please 172 000 what's
that a porter cabin
you know how will that
begin to resolve the issues in our ward
now that may not be possible but i do
feel that we're we are hostages to those
experts and
yet we are asked to make decisions that
affect our ward members for decades to
come
thank you philip over to you please
thank you german um always enjoy the
opportunity to uh
take questions in reverse order so um to
do with council mayor's point um
we are i mean planners i i sometimes say
planners know nothing they only know
what people tell them
um and we debate things here and you
know what you know as members and we
officers say well this is what the
technical advice is that we have
um
the planning process relies upon
reasonable objective advice and if
somebody has said to us we want five
pounds 500 pounds 500 000 pounds that's
what we report to you
um and in conversations with other
officers um it's
it's a slippery slope for officers to
start to unpick and challenge council
teas and stakeholders if we do it with
one why don't we do it with all of them
um and on what basis do we do that now i
know you will have your own experience
and might say
well we don't agree with that advice and
certainly i hear a lot about suffolk
county council highway aspect i'll come
back to that in a minute but in relation
to contributions the management process
of this typically is sell
um if a consultant comes to us and say
we want x amount of money
we we are not the experts they are the
subject experts
for you to challenge that we need some
basis on which we would start that
conversation probably beyond simply i
think
and you know the the situation with uh
health care is complicated because gp
practices aren't usually private
businesses so we're in a very strange
situation there
um and you know almost every application
i've seen come to this committee over
many recent years
public comment has been
gp gp practice provision is inadequate
um i we can we can query it we can
certainly query these matters
however
i think both an applicant the community
ourselves
at some point we have to rely on
somebody's advice and if the nhs are
saying this
then we are not better placed without
some other advisor on on medical matters
who knows more than we do
um so that's a bit of a challenge um
councilman
can i come back
i don't think i'm challenging what
they're saying i just would like to know
more
more detail um what are they proposing
to spend that money on and that
hopefully will then duplicate my
issues
and i understand that and we can
certainly ask that question i suspect
the answer might prove to be they have a
standard formula and an algorithm
we have seen that in the past for how
how the nhs
has come up with its contributions
and it hasn't always been as
sophisticated as you might hope or
tailored to individual circumstances so
yes we could do that and if we're going
to defer the application there's no
reason why we wouldn't ask the question
um can i come in on that thorough
question
on that question of deferral certainly
um
councillor passmore and
various members have talked about
uh highway improvements i missed the
question i i think i must miss the point
of concern that council reburn raised
but just thinking about this um
is is the point to defer the application
to check on the appropriateness of of
the kind of the act i mean these days
it's called active travel the active
travel arrangements
from within through the site so that we
are comfortable as a committee that
public um public access by cycling
walking using public transport is
satisfactory and to do that in a and an
active travel plan
yes
and
well from within through all of those
things um
and also to look at the high works and
junction improvements so that what we
secure here is
for the benefit of the whole allocation
site
in the stock market air action plan and
and
through the course of debate we talked
about potential
management of that and probably go away
and do that so we come back to you with
a package which actually says
as the developments come forward this is
how the parties see this happening
because this is not a conversation that
involves solely this applicant it's
conversation involves others there is
already as i think brad has referred to
there's a memorandum of understanding
about those highways improvements but we
are talking about trying to get comfort
between different landowners over
something that well you know this has
been
a challenging site to bring forward for
many years but am i i'd like to check
the committee that's correct but i also
think the point that john's made is that
we've had applications before us for 150
houses we've been told a single point of
access absolutely doesn't work
yet you've got 300 one does so we need a
bit more explanation as to why this one
works when others haven't rather than
just a map saying it's been signed off
yeah
council humphreys you want to come in as
well thanks mr chair um so it's the
comments up there i can't see any sort
of studying here on the killing effect
of the traffic on stone market you've
talked about the stow upland junction
and that's relevant
um but what about the other junctions
and what about the effect on the town
itself you've got a level crossing it's
already chopper block and newton road
particularly so i'd like to know what
study's been done
and also if you can please for all of us
give us definitions severe thank you
i hope you can pick up councillor
mansell's point around the width of the
road whether that's actually better off
being a cycleway
chairman if that's part of the active
travel conversation i think the
applicant's heard this officers have
heard this the other point i think i
missed was casually been referring to
open space and i wasn't quite sure what
point was being talked about there
because absolutely trying to type
something that i can then give to claire
as a wrap up of these issues
um thank you chair thank you
it was the fact that in the air reaction
plan and so on it had said the north of
the site would be open space to ensure a
defined area between
stone market and still upland and
there's only a patch there so it's just
what's the
qualification
for that and if i may well i've got the
my chair it can i just ask is it
possible
for us to consider both the ashes farm
and the darpa's farm site at the same
meeting together
because
then
and and
have it i know we're supposed to do one
on its own merits but have them so that
we've got all of the information for
both
yeah and then while we so we can all
cross-reference that in our papers and
while i appreciate we've got to make a
decision on one followed by a decision
on the other which order they whichever
order they come in at least we'll have
seen all that information and be able to
access it
for the two sides thank you
good
can i can i i mean can i take that away
problematic to insist upon it but if i
members would ask that um can you build
that into what i give
i think so can you get that info to
claire so that we can vote on that
sorry councilman oh mansell matheson
your hands up my apologist
yeah i mean i think
you know two two points really you know
one is is yeah accepting what mr isabel
is saying about well we have to rely on
our the various advisors or he has to
and uh planning department have to you
know the public expects us to
take that wider view that you know
members have talked about and we need to
we need to do that and and i think the
the other point is is that we we need
the assurance that
overall we are
sufficiently delivering the stone market
area action plan and that's why the
diapers point
is is well made again thank you thank
you councilman
yeah i just wanted to to say that this
this is really all about um trying to
get a little bit more uh certainty about
what is going to happen
um and um i'm not sure if there's any
scope for um something about the market
housing mix which was also been
mentioned we've talked a lot about
highways um is there um can that also be
looked into as to whether there's any
way of getting some certainty on on uh
market no market housing mix not the
viability of the affordables
whether we can have any sort of um
certainty on what we what the housing
mix might be
okay i think that's i think we've given
plenty plenty of homework there
and it's coming back in four weeks
[Laughter]
now
so chairman if i just pick that up
what i'm what i'm hearing is that you'd
like to defer for officers to review and
report to committee on the following
issues and that's firstly the
appropriateness of
active travel arrangements from within
and through the site that includes
obviously
cycling walking
bus etc
secondly uh to ensure that the highway
works to report back and ensure that the
highway works and junction improvements
the single access point the emergency
vehicle access and the delivery can be
secured and managed for the benefit of
the whole um stone market erection plan
allocation 6.13
and the development brief in a
programmed way so as to ensure there is
no cumulative residual highways impact
on highway highways within the town
thirdly to review the appropriateness of
open space provision and measures in
relation to the site and its separation
between stone market and stow upland
and
i also picked up that members wish to
see the diefest farm
application concurrently with reporting
back of these matters
the last point i did miss though
chairman sir
housing mix thank you
thank you
that has been proposed by council plasma
seconded by councillor humphreys
and we're now going to go to the vote
claire
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
so you are voting for deferral on those
for those reasons
or against deferral no well i'm just
explaining we're not voting for the
application
it's deferral is what we're voting on
yes or no
oh
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that
okay thank you i mean i think um that
was i mean that we covered a lot of
ground in in that in on this application
but actually
um it was important we did that and uh
it was a unanimous decision so thank you
and
very efficiently
yes absolutely
yeah okay what i propose is we take a
quick break um and we come back at five
to twelve
uh it's literally ten minutes uh five to
twelve by this clock i never know i know
slightly different other clocks but um
see you in 10 minutes
okay welcome back everyone uh we now
move on to the next planning application
which is
dc2106871 land adjoining principles
house
stoke road in thornton now hand over the
case officer elizabeth thomas to
introduce the application to committee
over to you
thank you chair
good morning members
so this application follows on from a
previous outline that was approved for
20 dwellings this is reserve matters
for land adjoining principles house
stoke road in thornton the other thing
just important to mention is this
application is running simultaneous to a
discharge of condition
for concurrent conditions which are
mentioned within the committee report
paragraph 2.3
but also the details of those for your
information only are within your tabled
papers
just to help you
just to provide some reassurance that of
of how they're coming along
the scheme uh contains 35 affordable
housing which is seven dwellings
so the application site is north west of
thunder and settlement the site is
within the settlement boundary but as i
say the outline's already established
the principle we're just looking at the
details here today
slightly wider view for you so it's as i
say north west of thornden you've got
other part of the settlement more
towards south
so that's the red line
of the site
the site was a former carrison site
including principal house and the former
school
so the main constraints of the site are
the tpo's tree preservation orders to
the front of the application and as i go
through the presentation you'll see that
they're unaffected by this development
but they're the main constraints of the
site
i don't know if i can zoom in hopefully
you can see that but this is the overall
block plan of the site which shows 20
dwellings
generally standard layout for this type
of development
but i will zoom in the next slide should
be a bit more detailed yep so this is
the south of the site which shows
some of the detached dwellings and some
of the semi-detached
as i say the tpo trees to the front of
the site as you can see they're
unaffected by this
and then looking at the north of the
site
again
some detached semi-detached but also the
plots with the yellow um which have got
yellow sort of dots on their their sheds
but they're the affordable housing
so the landscape plan
um can will contain um vegetation around
the front of the dwellings and there
will be some more trees within the site
this is showing you the northern part of
the site
i do apologize i can't zoom in on that
detail but that is also on the website
yep and then the south of the site again
you can see some more trees and
vegetation included within the scheme
and again those tpos to the front of the
site are are unaffected there
so looking at the details of some of the
dwell
the dwelling of the 20 dwellings in
the plot so this is a market house
it's two story four bedroom and it will
be black pan tiles and red brick
this is another market dwelling for plot
two
again detached
four bedroom red pan tiles and render
with a hip roof there so you can see
different different design forms to give
it some character
the third plot is a bungalow
two bedroom
and that will consist of black plantails
and buff brick
plot four similar to plot one
red plantails and red blick there
plot five
again another market house red panthers
and boarding
plot six we've got black panthers and
buff brick
similar to plot one there plot for plot
seven which is uh slate and render
plot eight will consist of red panthers
and red brick
plot nine
red panthers and render
and then these are two of the affordable
housing um
which will be for shared ownership
they're two-bedroom semi-detached
and they'll be red pan tiles and red
brick
plots 12 and 13
to 213 sorry that's black panthers and
buff brick that's a market
um
drilling
uh
sorry i just my click has gone slightly
okay
apologies there there's two two
duplicate slides um so 14 to 18 plots
these are affordable housings they will
be affordable rent
and red red plantails and red brick
and plots 19 to 20 are market and they
will be red pan tiles and render
so just to give you sort of a bit in
depth of the design the sort of form and
just to show that there will be various
characters within the scheme
as you will see from the the previous
site plan some of the dwellings will
contain
single story garages and some will
contain two-story garages it's mainly
the market houses
there'll be 47 parking spaces six
visitor parking spaces and 16 garages
three of which are double
and then these are just some images of
the front of the site so you can see
those tpo trees at the front there
sort of a wider shot of them so fairly
mature and significant to the scheme
and then that's looking into into the
site
the other thing just it's important to
mention that you'll probably know from
the committee report is that um
there is a high there was a holding
objection from the llfa with regards to
this planning application however within
your table papers
um that holding objection has been
superseded
from a new comment made on the 18th by
the
fa agreeing to approve this reserve
matters
as i say the
conditions are concurrent and they're
ongoing at the moment simultaneously to
this application there's also a
revised recommendation
for the scheme
that specifically
states that authority be delegated chief
planning officer to seek amendments to
the ecology mitigations and enhancements
as recommended by police services and as
such amendments the chief planner
consider appropriate the subspace and
detail and the subject there to that
authority be delegated to the chief
planning officer to grant reserve
matters approval subject to conditions
as summarized below and those as may be
deemed necessary by the chief planner
and that will enable
us as officers to continue to do the
good work with the negotiation on
condition
for the
surface water but also picking up the
[Music]
comments from ecology on the condition
21 mitigation
thank you
questions i guess you can ask the first
question is how we're heating the houses
[Music]
yeah that that condition which relates
to condition 14 on the outline that's um
that's not been submitted for discharge
and that's not um part of this reserve
matters that will be that would be dealt
with through the discharge of conditions
uh condition 14 which is specifically
with regards to the sustainability
element that's not been submitted so
those details haven't been provided but
i'm sure the agent might be able to give
you some indication of what they intend
to submit yeah we can ask ask the agent
and they come up okay other questions
yes casamansel uh thank you you showed
us lots of designs of different
properties and you said some of them
were affordable and some of them were
market housing
can you just confirm that there's
all of the houses meet the national
space standards and that there isn't any
difference in the quality of the build
between the ones that you said these are
affordable and these are market thank
you
yes to my knowledge they
all meet the quality aspects and you'll
also note from the committee report that
the disability forum have been consulted
um
so yes to my to my knowledge they they
meet the standards yeah
there's no difference in the sort of
build
process or quality of the market and the
affordables
i don't believe so no i think the only
thing i noticed should i check with the
applicant is the affordables don't have
chimneys but the affordable sorry the
affordables don't have chimneys but the
yeah but we'll check that
thank you chair that is my question um
on on the design of the housing um all
of the affordables
don't have chimneys
and then a couple of the market ones
plus the bungalow don't have a chimney
and that to me is cl you know is there a
reason why that's
you know it's a plot
that seems to be quite
yeah anyway what why do all the
affordables not have chimneys and
only a couple of the market housings
have chimneys that's my first question
i've got another
okay
and though um could you just clarify for
me there seems to be some um ambiguity
about the access to the playing field
area um
is that
access confirmed and sorted for the
residents on this site thank you
yes the the site plan shows i don't know
lucy if you can just get the if we just
get the plan back up for you um there is
an access through
to that field um
again apologies if that uh if that's
that block plan wasn't clear enough
on the screen
and the gates there are open gates for
anyone to access there's not a
restriction or anything no okay thank
you
thank you just count some maths
thank you yes the i probably should have
said that i i have been to the site um
when it was in use as a conference
center a couple of times and
i think also sat on a committee on one
of the earlier
developments there um but i was struck
that the um the the reason for the
holding objection from the flood
authority was um
about the dual use and i wondered what
uh
you know what what is so odd about this
site that the the um
the flood provision
you know sustainable urban drainage et
cetera
can't
also function as most others do and as
apparently we we expect them to
just for coming on that
reason
yeah sure um i think the main um concern
originally that the lf lff lead local
flood authority had with this was that
they recognized that this
scheme can provide
a perfectly functioning drainage system
but within the national planning policy
framework there is that policy 169 that
has that four sets of criteria
and it was the multifunctional benefits
in criteria d that was the concern of
the local
lead flood authority whereby
initially there was concerns whether it
could provide the amenity and the
biodiversity aspect but as the
concurrent
surface water drainage condition is
being negotiated at the moment it's
being found that the suds basin can be
provided
um and that the amenity aspect with
further work can be achieved which is
another reason why the lead local flood
authority have put in that additional
comment it within your table papers to
say that this is this is now considered
acceptable
they haven't you you've actually
delivered it so that's great yes good
thank you uh councillor
okay thank you very much so we'll move
on um
we don't have the parish council we
don't have an objective we don't have a
support but we do have the agent phil
cobalt so over to you
and three minutes please
thank you chairman uh as you've heard
the principle of erecting 20 dwellings
on this site has already been
established
by the excuse me outline planning
permission granted in 2019
site has also allocated for development
in the thornton neighborhood plan
this reserve matters application relates
solely to the appearance layout scale
and the landscaping of the site so no
other matters are for consideration
the layout of the proposed development
follows the indicative scheme submitted
with the outline application and that as
you've seen the proposed dwellings are
all of a very high standard of design
reflect the suffolk vernacular and
incorporate the use of traditional
materials
the scheme has evolved during the
application period with amendments been
made in order to address comments made
by consultees in particular the lffa and
the council's housing officer
and that's important because it was her
comments that changed the design of
the affordable homes including the
chimneys
and you'll know from the report that
your planning officers are satisfied
that the proposal is now acceptable in
both aesthetic and technical terms
the proposed dwellings will not be
reliant on fossil fuels they'll be
powered by air source heat pumps
at this point the full extent of
renewable energy has not been finalized
and this is because the scheme will be
subject to the new part l building rigs
which came into play last month and
which deal with renewable energy
the new building rigs require i think a
30
improvement on the previous standards
if the requirements for the building
rigs requires amendments to the scheme
which affect the external appearance of
the dwellings such as for solar panels
then a
further section 73 application will be
submitted to vary the designs
once the extent of the building rex
requirement are known the applicant will
then submit details to
discharge condition 14 of the outline
planning permission which deals
specifically with renewable energy
details of all other pre-commencement
conditions have already been submitted
scheme complies with the criteria of
relevant neighborhood policy th m3 and
on that basis i trust you'll be able to
support the recommendation
thanks very much questions i just got a
quick question any triple parking i
couldn't see on the map
i don't think so
thank you
council possible just a very quick one
um again my favorite subject about
porosity surface water presumably that
can all be covered in your discussions
to make sure we've got maximum
permeability in the development to go
underground water would you be happy to
do that
yes um yeah we're in a slightly strange
situation with her
lffa have recommended approval to the
reserve matters application but require
further information
on the
discharge of condition even though we've
submitted exactly the same information
for both applications
council event
um thank you chair i've got um three
questions if i may firstly um
the chimney question on affordable
housing if you could just um
yes after that well the the design for
the affordable housing units has changed
following discussions with the housing
officer
it was a completely different design
initially
um instead of it being a
terrorist have you got the plans of the
original scheme elizabeth
might be interesting just
okay
but it was a it was a slightly different
deal
the original design will be on the
website um the only what you're seeing
here is the the final sort of amendment
that was made
am i right phil i don't think the
original drawings of the affordables had
chimneys did they i i can't remember off
the top of my head i think they did but
they were slightly yeah i don't think
they had chimneys originally
i think could if i can come back then if
you know there's consideration as to
whether those
you know we want to ensure that the it's
um
you know the housing mix is blind as it
were and that's obviously a clear
difference so if that could be
looked at and can i just ask on the um
[Music]
neighborhood plan
i presume but i'd like to confirm that
you have had discussions with the
neighborhood plan group whether that's
for the parish council or the group
specifically and you mentioned about um
ensuring that the heating of these um
buildings would be
air source heat not not fossil fuel
um can you confirm that
and yet within the points to do with
sustainability and um so on that you
will pick up the points that were made
by the parish council
on those points thank you
yes um i've not had any direct
consultation with the parish council
on this application
i mean the site had already got
outline planning permission and it was
already an allocation
you know we think that the scheme
complies with the criteria of the
relevant policy i think it's three
but in terms of the renewable energy the
final renewable energy system it's a bit
of a chicken and egg situation because
the
it's not proposed at this stage because
the final working drawings haven't been
submitted to building regs so we don't
know what the new building rigs
requirements will be which is why we may
have to submit another section 73
application if the new building regs
require solar panels to be installed
thanks if i can come back because you
know on our papers page 172 there's a
variety of things that the parish
council has asked for that might be
covered by by that so could you
um assure us that you will take um
consideration of those
and within one of those also there's um
the
adequate pathways to the green space i'm
sure they're disability friendly can you
just confirm that thank you yeah there
is there is a direct route to the green
space um so i'm just trying to find the
parish council's
page
comments
yeah unfortunately the print off i've
got hasn't got the pages numbered
is the second page after the appendix of
the appendices
i'll find it in a minute hang on
oh yes here we go
uh some parish council note the drafts
tmp has been examined amended and
referendum parish councils but the
policies contained a given significantly
it's the list of bullet points at the
bottom saying that the parish council is
about to develop to ensure affordable
housing spill et cetera et cetera yeah
adequate pathways provided with
disability friendly and then various um
points about environmentally friendly
heating electric car charging points
yeah well
i mean most of those things will be
covered by the new building rigs i think
um
but things like the car charging points
they can be provided um
inside the garages
um
it's just the things where
the new building rigs affect the
external appearance of the buildings
where we may have to submit another
section 73 application just to vary the
designs just so we're clear the new
building rigs are coming in but we don't
have the detail yet is that correct so
you haven't got the detail yet this
application hasn't been submitted for
building regulation approval yet yeah
that normally comes after planning
permission has been granted
and the pathway disability-friendly
pathway
yeah there's a pathway is to be provided
through to the green space
yeah do you want to come in
yeah just to confirm for councillor ebon
the original affordable housings didn't
have chimneys either
yeah
uh
who's next to someone yes councillor
humphreys
mr thank you just a question and it's
reference chimneys i don't think i'd get
down to this but um it's about stigma
isn't it if you identify something as
being different and the affordable
housing is different that applies a
stigma potentially to the affordable
housing and that's
mentioned really by the council as well
and their points and it's important we
don't attach a stigma so therefore my
question is would it be possible to put
false chimneys on the affordable housing
i just say i don't want to preempt
anything but cancer string is going to
ask you exactly the opposite so let's
wait till we get to debate or all the
reverse let's wait till we get to debate
for that subject uh councillor matheson
well i was going to ask that no one else
had
whether the chimneys were actually
functional or aesthetic only um it
sounds like we just got that one
answered did we did we
some have chimney breasts with a chimney
coming out the top others don't no
that's not there are chimneys that's
that's the clue as to which are real and
which are false some have chimney
breasts on the side of the house so
they're real chimneys others don't
okay uh
uh cancer ebern did you want to come
back sorry can't sorry cancer manson
well i i was going to to say the
complete opposite of councillor
humphreys actually i've i've been
looking through the plans to work out
which ones need a chimney
and which ones don't and i would say i'd
rather only see chimneys where they are
actually got far better so that is a
personal matter i would like to see the
other chimneys all removed
sorry that's for debate not for now
you're giving an opinion but it's
already been asked you're giving an
opinion
no opinions at this stage because it's
points of clarification only councilor
matheson
you're done
okay we're gonna move on then
[Applause]
okay so we now have a statement from the
ward member who can't be here today so
i'll just read this out on behalf of
councillor andrew stringer
uh dear all i'll not be able to attend
your meeting on the 20th of july but
you'll be grateful if my thoughts as
district council be read out and
considered this application is broadly
in line with the recently adopted
thornton neighborhood plan and i note
the correspondence regarding the lack of
open suds this is disappointing as this
village has a demand for immunity space
for its residents and many rely on other
villages for similar
sorry for some recreational activities
moving on to the design it is very
disappointing we continue to see false
chimneys in some of the designs perhaps
this could be looked at
i also like the committee to double
check this development we'll be
utilizing heating and energy generation
opportunities that are sustainable many
of the designs that are suffolk
character although some quite on the
larger side
however plot 9 does not seem to be a
design familiar or in keeping with the
suffolk vernacular thank you for reading
this out kind regards andrew string
okay members so that's all the
information before us up to us discuss
debate and come to a conclusion cancer
hunters you were first
mr thank you so going to the ward
members point about chimneys it's
interesting because it keeps on going on
about the rural suffolk uh outlook and
design and everything else and it's all
very important and traditionally houses
in suffolk and everywhere else in the uk
had chimneys um so the traditional look
is to have chimneys so if we continue
with the chimney
debate because i've got no other issues
with this at all i've got to be honest
with you it's all about chimneys
we've already established that some of
the houses require chimneys
so would it not be simpler just to make
them all look the same false or not
that's all i'd like to say thank you
i think we've got to be careful not to
get drawn down into only talking about
chimneys i think what we need to have is
a broad range across the whole site and
we we're never gonna as we all have
different views on that and that is not
a reason to
to propose or refuse an application just
based on the chimneys so i'm just
mindful we don't get dragged into a big
discussion on chimneys yeah absolutely
right and i wasn't proposing anything
that's just discussing chimneys yeah
okay uh cancer ebay you were next
um thank you very much
it's nice to see or good to see an
application that's supported by the
parish council
and um
obviously it's within their
neighbourhood plan and seems to meet
what the neighbourhood plan has been
asking for which is which is good news
um
i'd just like to
ensure that the points that the parish
council has made are taken on board in
any sort of final iterations
um and that
the issues about you know
accessing suds as an open space area and
accessing having full
access for anyone with a disability is
included in the kind of final bits of
design and with regards to the
affordable housing and the market
housing um please can the developer
consider that we want them to be
um as
as just not as similar as possible but
we don't we want people not to have to
tell the difference between the market
housing and the affordable housing
however that may be but i'd be happy to
support this application thank you chair
thanks very much councillor matson
you're next
thank you yes yes i mean it is as
capital ebonus said it is welcome to see
something that
fits fits in with with all the policies
without
too many
sticky bits the only thing i perhaps
should have asked the agent actually but
can we can we have the disability
forum's request of 50
um meeting
part m42
included in in the conditions
is that a require is that a actual
requirement under the building rigs
because as if it is then it'll have to
be provided anyway
no
is part um degrees
what we've asked is can we have 50 of
them
meeting n42 which is
can you just comment on are we able to
request that point
well we i'm not sure if you've gone to
50
find the right button to push chairman
so
um
so this is a reserve matters application
it's not planning application um
i would have said that the description
what you're describing and i think the
case where we've done this before has
been in relation to an outline
application
not a reserved matters application
so i'm not convinced that that's a
reasonable thing to do at this point in
time
thank you okay a council pass more um
thanks i don't know whether rachel was
proposing i'd be very happy to second
the application if you were or were you
not
you are proposed some chairman i think
it's a very good application i think we
covered a lot of ground it ticks all the
boxes that we've spoken about and um so
i'm very happy to second it
okay anyone else wish to speak
so just so that we resolved chimneygate
um
am i right that the message to the
to the developer is let's have a mix
across all the housing either some with
some of that but not just the
affordables without so that you can't
tell the difference
is that the message from the proposer
and second then i'll bring in castlemen
from a proposal per second i would like
to see
as absolute minimal difference between
affordable housing and market housing
and personally if
if it's a workable chimney and it's got
a great chimney breast and it looked
fantastic with a chimney on it otherwise
i don't particularly see the need for
chimneys but i think
we can't design them sitting here but
that would be i was that would be my
view but the main point is that there
should not be a difference between the
affordables and the market housing thank
you councilman
yeah the point about chimney is that
council stringer makes on a regular
basis if you have a false chimney it's
guaranteed for 10 years the roof is
guaranteed for a lot longer so actually
by putting forced chimneys in you are
potentially causing an issue for
residents so um i i support the proposal
if you need a chimney because there's a
fire at the bottom of it fantastic
otherwise why put in something that's
not required
anyone else wish to come in
nope
okay so we'll go to the vote then i
think
claire over to you
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
okay thank you councilmember yes can i
go on four thank you
thank you numbers chair that's eight
votes for that's unanimous okay
well thanks everyone um do we have any
site inspection requests needed to be
reported to the committee
no check okay so now formerly closed
meeting at 12 26 thank you everyone for
your attendance today
you